well happy friday everybody whatever
you've got planned for the weekend hope
it's cool because we've got a lot of
heat coming your way we look outside
it's really nice out there we've got
mostly clear skies there is a little bit
of haze there's not a lot of smoke we
saw a lot more earlier in the week but
man it is so dry you've got to keep
yourself hydrated you're going to
dehydrate much quicker with the super
dry air humidity 10 or less at this
early hour and then all the heat that's
coming lots of beautiful 70s this
morning we even have some really nice
60s in mesquite indian springs pahrump
still warm in death valley the death
valley is going to be cooking this
weekend with temperatures up near 120
degrees so please be careful laughlin is
going to be in the one teens again this
afternoon rolling the smoke forecast
there's plenty of it around especially
for california central and western
nevada it looks like it might lift a
little bit for southern nevada and
that's great news for us maybe a little
bit of light haze the air quality
advisory is still in place today for a
little bit of smoke and haze especially
for sensitive groups and elevated ozone
too because of the extra hot
temperatures near record highs please
stay cool and hydrated lightweight light
colored clothing outdoors and always the
sunscreen and we're going to have
temperatures near 110 for many valley
neighborhoods next week we trade some
heat for monsoon humidity and a chance
for some thunderstorms i'll show you
that in the eight day forecast but let's
talk about a lot of tropical moisture
this is tropical storm ida and it is
going to gain some strength very quickly
as it rolls into the gulf of mexico and
heads right up to coastal louisiana late
in the weekend as a hurricane maybe even
a strong category three with winds over
a hundred miles an hour and is expected
to drop over a foot of rain it's going
to be a big hurricane for the folks in
louisiana in the deep south we're
looking at excessive heat warnings that
have already been in place since
yesterday for the lake and the river
northwest arizona but also now for lower
elevations of clark county southern
knight county those go into effect today
through sunday night i mean excuse me
saturday through sunday night we're
going to have very hot temperatures 83
up at mount charleston mid-80s for the
weekend remember they've got their
summer fun going friday saturday sunday
lots of good stuff to do up there and
cool off 108 for the lake 107 for the
valley and those southwest breezes
probably up to about 20 miles an hour
not as strong as they have been we'll
look for more heat this weekend 108 both
saturday sunday next week the numbers
come down as we say goodbye to august
but the humidity goes up we'll be
looking for a chance of thunderstorms on
wednesday and then back to sunshine with
90's for the rest of the week boy that
looks good